la esta edificación del cáncer de seno
se refiere a la extensión de la
enfermedad el estadio del cáncer depende
de varios factores entre ellos el tamaño
del tumor si está involucrado algún
ganglio linfático si el cáncer es
invasivo o no y si se ha esparcido a
zonas más allá del seno
el estadio 0 es considerado un cáncer de
seno no invasivo en este estadio no hay
evidencia de que las células
cancerígenas se hayan diseminado en el
tejido circundante del seno más allá del
conducto o lobulillos el estadio 1 es
considerado un estadio temprano del
cáncer de seno invasivo el tumor no mide
más de 2 centímetros de diámetro y no
hay evidencia de que las células
cancerígenas se hayan diseminado más
allá del seno
el estadio 2 se divide en subcategorías
2a y 2b
el estadio 2a es un cáncer de seno
invasivo en el que el tumor tiene un
máximo de 2 centímetros de diámetro y se
ha diseminado a los ganglios linfáticos
de la axila o el tumor mide entre 2 y 5
centímetros de diámetro pero no se ha
diseminado a ninguno de los ganglios
linfáticos
el estadio 2 p es diferente en el
sentido de que el tumor mide entre 2 y 5
centímetros y se ha diseminado a los
ganglios linfáticos de la axila o el
tumor mide más de 5 centímetros pero no
se ha diseminado a los ganglios
linfáticos de la axila
el estadio 3 es considerado un cáncer
localmente avanzado y también se divide
en subcategorías 3a 3b y 3c
se pueden presentar dos escenarios
principales con el cáncer de seno de
estadio 3 a 1 cuando el tumor no mide
más de 5 centímetros de diámetro pero se
ha diseminado a los ganglios linfáticos
de la axila que se están uniendo entre
sí y formando grupos el cáncer también
puede diseminarse a los ganglios
linfáticos cerca del esternón el segundo
escenario para el estadio 3a es muy
similar al anterior excepto que el tumor
mide más de 5 centímetros de diámetro y
los ganglios linfáticos de las axilas no
están unidos entre sí ni a otros tejidos
a diferencia de los demás estadios en el
estadio 3 ve el tumor puede tener
cualquier tamaño y se ha diseminado a la
piel del seno oa la pared del pecho este
estadio también puede incluir bultos en
la piel del seno o inflamación del mismo
en el estadio 13 el tumor también puede
ser de cualquier tamaño y también se ha
diseminado a las zonas de los ganglios
linfáticos por encima o debajo de la
clavícula la pared del pecho y o la piel
del seno el estadio 4 es considerado
metástasis distante lo que significa que
el cáncer se ha diseminado a otros
órganos y partes del cuerpo